hello everyone this game comes as a
suggestion from a subscriber Nick
Thoresen and he suggests that I should
show the first game played in space or
this game here played between astronaut
Greg Greg Chamitoff and the NASA ground
control I actually thought I was
preparing the first ever chess game
played in chess but it turned out I was
actually analyzing the other one between
Greg and NASA ground control but I will
show the first game played in space a
couple of videos after this one so it
was played in 2008 in August and well
well it's a very interesting game you
know playing from space astronauts vs.
ground control it actually made me
wonder about other things is it really
one of the first games played in one of
the first chess games played in outer
space
probably not I mean somewhere out there
in a distant planet in a distant galaxy
surely there are civilizations that have
evolved to the stage that they probably
have their own version of the ultimate
intellectual game that is chess on earth
but you know another planets it could be
it could be something totally different
so this is what interests me what do you
think if if another civilization would
create such a game would it would it in
any way compared to chess or would it be
would it even be on a rectangular board
I would maybe be a circle would it be a
sphere would it well what would it look
like so and what would influence the
game to evolve the way that chess
evolved on earth so that's that's
something that interests me but okay
let's get back to this game here Greg
Chamitoff the astronaut has the white
pieces and he plays d4 NASA ground
control responsible to d5 we have a
Knight to c3 the chicken variation c6
Bishop to f4 and Knight to f6
we have Knight to f3 Knight B D 7 e 3 e
6 Knight to e5 and here we have Queen to
a5 pinning the knight on c3 Bishop to d3
Greg simply continues developing we have
Knight captures Bishop captures and
Bishop to a3
when I saw this move I thought it was a
it was a not not a mouse slipper but
that it was a wrong notation I thought
actually Bishop to b4 was the move here
but it actually makes sense I mean if
white captures he will ruin his pawn
structure and black will capture the
knight on c3 and on the other hand you
are threatening to capture the b2 pawn
with an attack on the rook and the night
so an interesting move by the NASA
ground control Queen to see one
Greg defenseless and we have a bishop
back to before now now there is a threat
of Bishop captures night but we'll see
how it goes here Greg simply castles and
the NASA ground control play b6 and
while you do have the option of actually
winning a pawn here if you play Bishop
captures pawn cappers and Queen captures
you did win a pawn but look at all the
dark squares and I don't think NASA
ground control wants to allow this as
Greg is an astronaut astronaut so I
don't think he will have a problem
exploiting the space left behind
so after this castling move b6 was
played a for now
Bishop to a6 and this Bishop a6 is
actually a terrible move as it really
really locks in the Queen there on a5
and the Greg immediately takes advantage
of this he plays in Knights to b5 and
what's the idea here the idea is that if
you capture the knight see captors
Knight a capture some b5 the Queen is
trapped and the rook will grab the Queen
on the next move or Queen will have to
grab rope either way black loses the
Queen here so after night to b5 NASA
ground control castles we have Bishop
captures on f6 GTRs on f6 and c3 now
attacking the bishop seek after some b5
as there really is no way to avoid this
and now instead of 8 captures on b5
trapping the Queen this would result in
Bishop captures rook captures Queen
Bishop captures on d3 now both of white
rooks are under attack and after
something like rope to a-1 simply
capture the rook Queen captures and
Bishop back to d6 sure you're better
here as white but black still has two
ropes and a nice
bishop he will still post problems for
you so after this seek after some b5
Greg doesn't immediately recapture a key
after some b5 rather he plays rook to d1
now there is no rockin f1 for black to
attack after white recaptures this and I
have to locate the c8 we have eight
captures on b5 now Bishop captures on c3
rook captures Queen Bishop captures Rose
and Queen to be one and it's not just
that you want a queen but you you're
also going to win a win one of these
bishops as NASA ground control plays
Bishop to b7 but now comes the b4 and
now your a5 Bishop is trapped so f5 you
know doesn't really matter what you play
a captures me captures and now rook to
c1 exchanging rooks
a4 rook captures Bishop captures and
Queen to b4 we have Bishop to d7
but now simply Queen captures on a4
rocked the c8 and here it does seem like
there is a threat of rook to c1 check
perhaps but Greg isn't afraid of this he
simply plays Queen characters on a7 NASA
tries to rook to c1 check Bishop to f1
blocking and it seems like black can
actually pull this off by playing Bishop
captures on b5 there's no way to defend
the bishop on f1 the bishop can't move
it's pinned but actually white can solve
this pretty easily with Queen to b8
check King g7 and simply grab the bishop
with the Queen so unfortunately there is
no way for NASA to recover from this
after Bishop to f1 Bishop to see it was
played but now it's pretty much over b6
b7 coming King to g7 now b7
Bishop captures Queen captures and after
King to have six f3 and h6 NASA decided
to resign this game as it's only a
matter of time there's really no point
king is coming to f2 the bishop will
then be activated twitter d3 b file
doesn't really matter even the king is
coming into the game and it'll be over
very quickly at for pretty much locks
the king there on f6 so there's no point
in resuming this game and in this
position NASA
the game and a wonderful game by the
astronaut Greg Chamitoff
or Gregory I believe it's his full name
after he won this game he then started
playing simultaneous games like six six
simultaneous games against different
space stations on earth and I don't
really know the result of those games
but this game he handled pretty pretty
you know
decently I'm interested how he would
fare against for example the Russian
space station on earth so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Paul Miller and
Barak was on par Mac for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it and I really am interested
what do you think if chess a game like
chess developed some in some other
civilization what do you think it could
it could look like what would maybe be
different and what would maybe be the
goal of the game so yeah thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon